during the show we've spoken about
schools care homes businesses all of
them are pretty heavily affected by the
coronavirus lockdown last Sunday the
Prime Minister laid out a roadmap for
easing that lockdown but everybody is
going to be watching closely to see what
happens to infections as measures are
relaxed to discuss all of this and more
we can head to central London where
we'll be joined by the Chancellor of the
Duchy of Lancaster Michael golf at mr.
golf very good to see you this morning I
wonder if we might start with the
schools the school system and there will
be parents up and down the country at
the moment struggling with this decision
I suppose the problem for the government
is pretty straightforward the one thing
that parents would wish you to guarantee
is the one thing that you can't
guarantee that their children will not
get covered 19 as a result of them
returning to school well we can
guarantee that steps are being taken in
order to ensure the children and those
who work in schools are as safe as
possible
now manifestly the only way in which you
can ensure that you don't get over to 19
is by remaining at home throughout and
having no social contact with anyone we
want to proceed in a balanced way in
order to ensure the children we've just
been hearing about the impact on their
mental health of isolation children have
the opportunity to be back in school to
benefit from learning and as a result to
ensure that their future can be more
secure but what chance is there and many
parents and teachers are asking this is
not this morning what chance is there
that that children particularly younger
children can socially distance can
follow the rules and recommendations
around hygiene I mean my four-year-old
is a biological weapon at the best of
times
stick him into a school environment and
goodness knows what will happen well
other countries have succeeded in making
sure the children can return to school
safely other European countries like
Denmark have done so and of course the
nature of what happens in the classroom
has changed and and it is the case that
instead of children working in a group
around a table they're sitting at desks
separate from each other and as a result
they are able to learn they are able to
benefit from being in school we
recognize that of course this requires
careful working with teachers but the
the leaders of some of the countries
very very best schools have said that
they can ensure the children and
teachers and other workers are safe and
they are proposing to return on the 1st
of June with children in reception year
1 and year 6 in primary schools
receiving education we know that much of
the independent sector has already ruled
out returning to school on the 1st of
June when parents are sitting at home
parents of comprehensive school students
noticing that the you know the parents
of children who are going to Eton don't
have to make that decision how can you
reassure them that the schools will be
safe that teachers will be protected and
that children will be able to go to
school and come home free from Kovach 19
well my understanding is that many
independent schools will be returning
that the trade body for independent
schools that looks after children of
primary age has said that its cause will
be returning and we've also had the
leaders of some of the the most
important Academy chains in this country
saying that they are confident that
children in the designated years can be
taught in an appropriate way we know
that if children contract coronavirus
that the impact is significantly less
they're less likely to have symptoms
less likely to have serious symptoms
than older citizens but of course we
also want to make sure that teachers and
other work is a safe and we've been
assured by those who as I say lead our
very best schools that a stage and
careful return is an appropriate way of
making sure that the children most in
need get the education that they deserve
because it's not a feeler so the
teaching more than our school the more
the divide between those children who
are in privileged circumstances and
those children who are in less
privileged circumstances goes so are the
unions the teachers that are complaining
about returning to school in their mind
without without
good protection of them are the union
scaremongering no I think it's important
for us to continue a conversation with
all the representatives of of teachers
organizations it's entirely
understandable that unions and others
would want to have reassurance about the
health and safety of their members
that's that's the job of unions the job
of government is to work with unions
local authorities and those who lead our
schools in order to ensure that we can
have a safe and orderly return and that
conversation as I say has been led over
the last few weeks in a way which has
given confidence to those who are in
charge of our best schools that they can
return and I think that if we can make
sure that we carry on those
conversations we can provide a safe
environment for teachers and for
children and we can also make sure that
children particularly those from the
least advantaged homes have the benefit
of a good education so that we can begin
to make up on some of the progress that
will inevitably have been lost during
this period of lockdown
what effect does the modeling suggests
that reopening the schools will have on
the are number sorry Neil I missed that
question sorry sorry I'll speak a little
bit more lively just in case what effect
what effect if any does the modeling
suggest that will happen to the our to
the our number after we reopen schools
well we know that any progressive
relaxation of the rules risks they are
number giving higher but the really
important thing is provided the our
number remains below one and the rate of
infection is falling then we're making
progress in the fight against the
disease and we know that the our number
is below one and we also know that the
number of people being infected is
falling day by day just explain to to
viewers not necessarily the ends are
notes of how we come up with the our
number itself but it but it's utility
because there appear to have been a bit
of a difference of opinion at one point
where the Prime Minister saying it is
absolutely central to the way in which
we exit the lockdown restrictions at
Janey Harris appearing to dilute that
don't what is your view I mean does it
all come down to the our number
the oil number is absolutely critical
but we also needed to make sure that
we're looking at the are number which is
the most important statistic alongside
other statistics so if you've got our
below one and infections are falling
then you're winning in the fight against
the disease but why would lockdown
conditions be eased in parts of the
country with potentially at dramatically
different our numbers
well the key thing is is the are number
below one that's the single most
important determinant and then is it the
case that infections are falling overall
if you look at countries like Germany in
France the our number is it at different
levels in different parts of those
countries but again the French president
of the German Chancellor have outlined
the vital importance of beginning to
ease the lockdown and it is something
that you need to do in a careful and a
balanced way as the Prime Minister has
said you take careful steps in order to
ensure that you can keep our below one
and if that is combined with infections
falling then you can progressively lift
more and more of the restrictions can we
be certain that as of this moment the
our number is below zero if it's below
one I should say because of that that
that lag factor that there has in its
construction about two weeks I think yes
again the the our number is the product
of scientific modelling and scientists
give a range in order to make sure that
all of us recognize that a while that
trying to be as absolutely precise as
possible it is impossible to state with
absolute precision what the our number
is that's why we have that range but the
range that scientists do give us is
clearly below one and it is also the
case as I say
but because infections are falling we
know that we're in a in territory where
we're making progress against the
disease one figure that I'm absolutely
certain you'll be able to put a number
on relates to contact tracing of course
going to be incredibly important as we
move into the next phase of dealing with
kovat 19 how many people have we
recruited to the contact tracing schemas
yet just over 17,000 17,000 so we are on
track for next week then
yes the here I have to praise the work
of the health secretary Matt Hancock a
in the past people have seen Matt and
the government set ambitious targets and
they said oh the target on testing that
won't be met Matt met that target it's
now the case as I say that more than
17,000 people have been recruited for
contact tracing so we're on course to
meet that target again it's more
evidence that we have in Matt an
energetic and determined health
secretary who is throwing everything
into the fight against the virus and
making sure that we mobilize a united
national effort and when will they be be
trained be in a position to actually be
working on the scheme when do we think
we can have the contact tracing scheme
up and running in the way in which you'd
like to see it to try and finally get
this covered 19 at spread under under
control by the end of this month
Frank I wonder if we can turn to
something that was said by the health
secretary just have a few days ago I
mean you'll understand the helix going
news we've done a decent amount of
reporting on the situation within Social
Care particularly within care homes my
colleague Nick Martin's done some
fantastic work on that the health
secretary suggested that a protective
ring had been thrown around our care
homes can you justify that statement yes
I think that's absolutely right what
we've seen is detailed instructions
going to care homes about how we can
make sure that we have appropriate
infection control additional support
going to local authorities and to care
homes in order to help them through this
difficult period and we've also seen
fewer people being discharged from
hospital into care homes this year than
last year but in terms of throwing a
protective ring around care homes one
might expect that in throwing that
protective ring you wouldn't then put
covered 19 positive patients into care
homes well as I say it is the case that
term we have had fewer people going from
hospitals into care homes this year than
last year
and it's also the case that for every
patient who is released
appropriate clinical judgment is made
and if patients are discharged into care
homes is on the basis that that is
appropriate and that is a more effective
and a safer place for them to be than in
a hospital I'm sorry to labor the point
but it was suffering from acute forgive
me hospitals of are there for you who
suffering from acute conditions that
need particular care but hospitals are
also places where there is a a serious
risk of infection as well so doctors
will weigh up that judgment and make a
judgment about the most appropriate
setting um but again I I'm sorry to
labor the point it is difficult to
reconcile the health secretary
suggesting that a protective ring had
been put around the care sector and
covered 19 positive patients being
removed from hospitals and placed in
care homes which we may hear anecdotally
from a number of people working within
the care sector they were accepting
those patients against the care homes
wishes well I don't know of any example
of patients being accepted against the
wishes of the professionals against the
instructions of the professionals more
broadly there is clear guidance on what
to do if someone in a care home does
have covered 19 clear guidance on
infection control and isolation and that
guidance properly observed helps to
protect those who work in care homes as
well as those who are in care homes
becoming the guidance the government
values that was in place until the 13th
of March Mr Gove says this it remains
very unlikely that people receiving care
in a care home will become infected no
restrictions or special control measures
are required in these settings while a
member of staff all resident is waiting
for a lab test for kovat 19 no need to
close or send staff home at this point I
understand that the government advice to
care homes has changed we understand
that you have gotten rather better at
getting the testing done within the care
sector and in the NHL's s itself but
again we put covered 19 positive
patients into communities in which some
of the most vulnerable and susceptible
people were already living I just don't
understand how
we can reconcile that with the idea of
putting a protective ring around the
care sector well the first thing to say
is as as you quite rightly acknowledge
that the guidance has changed at
different points and that kinds was
issued at a time when we had a a
different phase of the infection and the
second thing to say is that Oh people
are only released from hospital if the
clinical judgment is that it is better
for them to be in a different setting
and the number of people who've been
discharged from hospitals into care
homes has been declining throughout this
pandemic and it's also 40 percent less
than it was at this time last year and
as I mentioned it has been the case that
we've laid out an action plan for care
homes we've spent 3.2 billion pounds
given that money to local authorities in
order to ensure better support for care
homes and we've also been providing
personal protective equipment for people
in care homes as well as clearer
guidance on how to isolate patients
effectively and you're a very busy man
mr. Gope I wonder if we might turn your
attention to two brexit just for a
second
reports this morning and the talks of
the European Union might be at the point
of breaking down sadly we know that
within the next 14 15 days or so is that
is that your understanding is it really
that bad no there's a difference of
course between the UK's position and the
--use position the EU want us to accept
their rules even though we're outside
their club and they want to have access
to our fish even though we've left a
word making it clear to the EU that we
can't do a deal on those terms but I am
confident that a deal is there to be
done it just requires a degree of
flexibility on the EU side which I'm
sure that they will appreciate they need
to show um but what does all of this
mean for the potential for checks
between at Northern Ireland and the rest
of the United Kingdom it certainly seems
there if we are to exit with however you
want to describe it Australia's style
deal nor deal whatever ours if we come
out on those terms
it does seem absolutely certain to some
people that there will have to be those
checks
well the the northern island protocol
which we are determined to uphold
stresses that there should be unfettered
access for goods from Norland coming in
to Great Britain
um and it's only those goods that go
into Northern Ireland which are at risk
of going to the Republic of Ireland that
will require a chance won't they well
there are checks at the moment there are
epidemiological checks in order to
ensure that we we safeguard the single
epidemiological zone for animal health
that is the island of Ireland but we
want to ensure that we continue to have
the greatest degree of flexibility and
as I say unfettered access the goods
coming from Northern Ireland into the UK
and as for the prime minister they're
back into work after that in that period
in hospital how is he doing I mean how
is his health how obviously those
perhaps not as much face to face contact
as as pre lockdown but you'll certainly
have an idea of how he's coping his son
of the Prime Minister's well I mean he's
determined focused working hard holding
all of us in the cabinet to account in
order to deliver in the in the fight
against poverty and he's also determined
to ensure that we support our public
sector workers and throw our arms around
them and so if the Prime Minster is in
good form and obviously we face a very
serious situation he's determined to do
everything that he can and he's showing
great leadership well hopefully we'll be
bear-hugging in the studio sometime soon
Michael Gough really good to see this
morning thanks for being with us